«Ich war eingeladen in Israel,
an einem Wochenende.
Verwandte feierten dort ein Familienfest ...
... und meine Grosscousine
nahm mich mit an eine Party.
Das war ihre Geburtstagsparty, und
dort haben wir uns kennen gelernt.»
«Oh ja, er hat typisch schweizerische Eigenschaften.
Erstens: Er ist nicht fordernd.
Und manchmal sage ich ihm:
Du musst etwas sagen!
Du solltest dich öfters wehren.
Sonst funktioniert es nicht!
Dann sagt er mir:
So läuft es nicht, hier.
Also, er ist nicht fordernd.
Ich schon. Offensichtlich.
Aber ich versuche, mich zurückzuhalten.
Sagen wir's so.»
«Viel Flugzeug, am Morgen früh.
Ein Glück, dass es einen frühen
Flug gibt in Tel Aviv, ...
... dass man am Montagmorgen
pünktlich im Büro ist .
Es ist anstrengend.
Wenn man das alle paar Wochen macht,
ist das schwierig.
Ich habe es nicht so schlimm empfunden,
es braucht einfach viel Logistik.
Es ist auch abenteuerlich,
das hat mir gefallen.
Ich reise gern.»
«Ich hatte eine lange und anspruchsvolle
Karriere in der Armee.
Ich war Offizier und arbeitete fast zehn Jahre lang
für den israelischen Geheimdienst.
Das war ein 24-Stunden-Job ...
... und die Vorstellung, dort zu kündigen,
war für mich eine Erlösung.
Ich dachte, es könnte eine interessante Erfahrung
sein, an einen ruhigeren Ort zu ziehen ...
... und nicht mehr so viel zu arbeiten.»
«Wozu ich ermutigen würde, ist:
Dass man betreffend Sprache
etwas genauer hinschaut.
Damit der Partner, der aus dem Ausland kommt,
die Landessprache besser lernt.
Hätte ich mit Annette nicht hebräisch gesprochen,
wäre es vielleicht jetzt anders ...
... nun macht ihr das Deutsch Mühe.
Da mache ich mir einen Vorwurf.
Das ist mein Ratschlag.
Und sonst:
Einfach machen!»